>>> BIGFOOT.
THE LOCH NESS MONSTER.
ALL RARELY SEEN.
ALL SHROUDED IN MYSTERY.
TONIGHT WE'RE HEADED TO THE
WOODS OF WESTCHESTER COUNTY TO
SEARCH FOR THE MOST ELUSIVE
LEGEND OF ALL, HILLARY RODHAM
CLINTON.
>> WAIT, DID YOU HEAR THAT?
>> WITH MY PARTNER, COOP DIXON.
>> THERE'S SOMETHING HERE, MAN!
>> THIS IS "THE HUNT FOR HILL."
OUR SEARCH BEGINS IN THE WOODS
OF CHAPPAQUA WHERE HILLARY
CLINTON HAS RECENTLY BEEN
SIGHTED BY A BUNCH OF WHITE
PEOPLE WITH FACEBOOK ACCOUNTS.
WHERE WAS SHE NOW?
WE SET OUT TO FIND HER.
TRAP HER.
AND THANK HER.
AND FOR THAT WE NEEDED HELP.
>> SO MICHELLE, YOU'VE SEEN
HILLARY CLINTON?
>> I HAVE.
I WAS IN MY KITCHEN WASHING PANS
WHEN I SAW SOMETHING MOVING
THROUGH THE WOODS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
IT WAS BLOND, ABOUT 5'6".
IT SEEMED LIKE IT KIND OF WANTED
?
TIME TO ITSELF SO I IMMEDIATELY
STARTED RUNNING AFTER IT.
>> HEY, WAIT!
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU!
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> HILLARY!
HILLARY, WAIT!
I THINK IT'S HER.
>> THAT'S HER.
YOU DID A GREAT JOB.
>> WE DECIDED TO CHECK OUT THE
SPOT WHERE MICHELLE HAD HER
SIGHTING TO SEE IF THERE WAS ANY
TRACE OF HILL.
>> HEY, RAFE?
YOU'RE GOING TO WANT TO SEE
THIS.
>> THAT IS A WOMAN'S SHOE RIGHT
THERE SIZE 6.
LOOK, SEE HOW THERE'S NO HEEL?
>> IT'S HILLARY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> SHE WAS DEFINITELY CLOSE.
SO I DECIDED TO TRY AND
COMMUNICATE WITH HER.
>> HA HA HA HA!
>> WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> SHH!
HA HA HA HA!
>> IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK.
>> JUST HOLD ON.
HA HA HA HA!
>> HA HA HA HA!
>> WE COULD HEAR HER LAUGH BUT
WE COULDN'T SEE HER.
AND IT WAS GETTING DARK SO WE
DECIDED TO LURE HER TO US WITH
THE ONE THING WE KNEW WOULD
ENTICE HER, AN ARTICLE ABOUT THE
RECOUNT IN WISCONSIN.
WE PLACED IT AT THE EDGE OF THE
WOODS, SET UP OUR NIGHT VISION,
AND WAITED.
SHE NEVER SHOWED.
BUT THE NEXT MORNING WHEN WE
CHECKED, THE ARTICLE HAD CLEARLY
BEEN READ.
BECAUSE IN THE VERY BOTTOM
CORNER THERE WAS A LITTLE NOTE.
>> THAT'S OUR GAL.
>> THAT SAID "THANK YOU, H."
IT WAS OUR LAST DAY IN CHAPPAQUA
AND WE HAD JUST ONE MORE IDEA.
BUT IT WAS A CRAZY ONE.
>> HELLO?
>> YOU SAY YOU ARE ONE WITH THE
TREES.
>> YES.
I HAVE LIVED MY WHOLE LIFE IN
THESE CHAPPAQUA WOODS.
THE TREES WHISPER THEIR SECRETS
TO ME.
>> CAN YOU ASK THEM WHERE
HILLARY CLINTON IS?
>> OF COURSE.
ONE MOMENT.
[ GIBBERISH ]
HA HA HA HA!
OH!
SHE'S BUYING EGGS AT A GROCERY
STORE.
>> NEXT WEEK, THE SEARCH MOVES
TO A SHOP RITE.
ONLY ON "THE HUNT FOR HILL."
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]